bonsoir Monsieur peladeau j'ai fini
enfin vous avez mis la main sur freedom
mobile cette transaction que vous
souhaitiez et qui vous permet d'entrer
dans le marché du Canada anglais
particulièrement dans l'ouest du Canada
et vous allez devenir Vidéotron le
quatrième grand acteur du secteur des
télécoms au Canada est-ce que vous allez
devenir aussi une entreprise aussi
grande que belle que Telus que Rogers
dans le secteur de télécommunication je
vous pose la question qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez et clairement ce fut une
longue aventure venez de le mentionner
dans l'acquisition et des
rebondissements nombreux
Bureau de la concurrence la confédérale
etc au départ nous n'avions pas été
retenus par Rogers pour en faire
l'acquisition probablement pour une
raison assez simple c'est que donc notre
entrée ici au Québec dans le sans fil
avait perturbé de façon significative le
marché c'est au Québec que nous étions
en mesure de proposer pour l'ensemble
des Canadiens donc les plus bas tarifs
et certainement que le Bureau de la
concurrence a de prix acte et pas
uniquement le Bureau de la concurrence
comme vous le savez également aussi le
ministère donc le ministre de champagne
c'est également aussi saisie ainsi que
le CRTC de plus en plus dorénavant avec
le nouveau leadership madame intrades
qui est justement forte de son
expérience en matière de concurrence va
faire en sorte qu'il y a un véritable
pour répondre à votre question dans le
fond un quatrième joueur et nous
entendons bien évidemment jouer cette
cette aventure c'est une exigence
d'ailleurs que vous baissiez les prix et
est-ce que vous travaillez parce que je
aujourd'hui les chiffres les données
mobiles coûte 26 fois plus cher au
Canada qu'en France par exemple et 115
fois plus cher qu'en Israël vous vous
avez l'engagement de d'arriver à faire
baisser de 20% les forfaits
télécommunications vous allez faire ça
rapidement oui les ça devait être
annoncé donc on a une nouvelle
tarification depuis déjà quelques
semaines nous avons pris un guillemets
possession de l'entreprise dès le début
du mois d'avril et nous avons déjà
proposé donc déjà 20% de moins
exactement et même peut-être davantage
ça dépend des forfaits c'est parce que
c'est pas toujours simple de comparer
les prix parce que les forfaits sont
nombreux et les technologies sont
différentes également êtes-vous sur le
4G ou sur le 5G je peux pas entrer trop
dans le détail mais une comparaison
simple n'est pas toujours facile à faire
mes choses certaines donc il y a
nettement un changement et un
environnement concurrentiel dorénavant
au Canada est-ce que l'expansion grandes
entreprises puis Vidéotron si je me
trompe pas à peu près 80% de vos revenus
en ce moment là est-ce que l'expansion
de l'entreprise québécart passe par
l'ouest du Canada par cette transactions
que vous avez fait clairement clairement
et c'était nous l'avons nous avons eu
l'occasion de le dire à plusieurs
reprises
la maturité du marché québécois est
indéniable évidemment historiquement
comme tableau distributeur nous avons
été le premier tableau distributeur
historique à s'engager dans la
téléphonie mobile il y a déjà de ça donc
en 2006 d'ailleurs nous avions loué le
réseau de Rogers nous avons participé
aux enchères après bien s'assurer qu'il
y a les conditions nécessaires pour que
nous le fassions nous avons acheté du
spec en 2008 et par la suite donc nous
avons construit notre réseau pour
s'assurer justement qu'on puisse
adéquatement servir notre clientèle ici
maintenant 23 parts de marché que nous
avons au Québec alors que c'est un
environnement nettement plus
concurrentiel que dans l'Internet par
exemple où il y a un seul concurrent
alors que dans la téléphonie mobile nous
sommes nombreux vous l'avez mentionné
nous et ça fait déjà plusieurs une
quinzaine d'années que nous sommes
quatre ici au Québec ce qui était pas le
cas pour le reste du Canada allez-vous
bâtir des infrastructures ou simplement
louer les infrastructures de vos
concurrents pour pour offrir la
téléphonie mobile
nous évidemment la transaction a fait de
mon bal et déjà donc l'acquisition
d'infrastructures
films et la continuation d'une
entreprise qui s'appelait win auparavant
qui d'ailleurs participé aux enchères en
2008 ils ont construit une bonne partie
de réseau en Ontario ensuite par la
suite avec l'acquisition de chats chat
en construit une partie du réseau en
Colombie-Britannique et en Alberta et
nous entendons élargir ce périmètre ce
territoire d'ailleurs nous avons pris
l'engagement auprès du gouvernement
lorsque nous avons participé aux
enchères les dernières enchères celles
qu'on appelle le 3500 MHz pour justement
faire en sorte que c'était une des
conditions de participation à l'enchère
nous avons 7 ans pour construire le
réseau en attendant
au sans fil nous avions manqué la
transaction Fido peut-être que vous en
souvenez donc il y avait une
restructuration financière et bon nous à
ce moment-là on avait un bilan qui nous
permettait pas de l'acquérir mais ce qui
est important pour nous c'est de savoir
que nous allons nous engager dans le
sans fil et nous l'avons fait dès 2006
ça je le comprends monsieur peladeau la
question je vous demande est-ce que
est-ce que l'avenir
média du groupe média est
particulièrement du Groupe TVA est-ce
qu'il y a un avenir là-dessus quand on
voit les pertes en question quand je
vous entends parler surtout des télécoms
clairement donc il y a pas de doute des
médias est un domaine difficile et Dieu
sait si je suis pas le seul à le dire
vous regardez donc les résultats de
l'ensemble des entreprises médiocres que
ce soit en Amérique du Nord ou que ce
soit en Europe nous sommes tous logés à
la même enseigne ça veut dire quoi
Monsieur peladeau qu'est-ce que vous
allez faire est-ce que d'autres
compressions voulez-vous vous départir
du groupe non on n'a pas l'intention de
s'en débarquer c'est certain que ça va
requérir un changement de culture ça
veut dire travailler autrement ces
choses-là vont arriver au fur et à
mesure que le temps passe mais il va
falloir effectivement penser autrement
déjà donc de s'engager vers le numérique
nous l'avons fait depuis déjà un certain
nombre d'années est-ce que nous allons
être en mesure de pouvoir générer autant
de revenus que nous en ait générions à
l'époque lorsque on avait pas un
monopole mais certainement donc une part
de marché ou est-ce que la télévision
constituait presque un actif
on a pour les publicitaires d'aller mais
c'est plus le cas maintenant vous le
savez donc on l'a dit à plusieurs
reprises 80% des revenus publicitaires
sont accaparés par les Gafa est-ce que
d'autres compressions qui sont admis à
TVA on peut pas dire qu'il y en aura pas
est-ce que il va en avoir oui proprement
au fur et à mesure que le temps passe on
pourra pas vivre avec des pertes de
celles comme celle que nous avons vécu
au premier trimestre indéfiniment il y a
personne il y a aucune entreprise qui
est capable de vivre avec des pertes
est-ce que vous allez fermer TV à ce
sport
une situation bien particulière donc
depuis plusieurs années nous sommes nous
avons différents avec belles nous avons
le bénéfice d'avoir la juste valeur
marchande pour les redevances de TVA
sport de la part de tous les
distributeurs ici au Québec et dans le
reste du Canada pour le francophone la
seule entreprise qui n'a pas ne veut pas
nous donner la même redevance que celle
que nous avons des autres distributeurs
pensons à Cogeco par exemple et deviner
c'est quoi c'est qui ces belles télé
pourquoi parce que belle télé est
également aussi propriétaire de RDS ils
sentent ils sont en conflit d'intérêt et
ils ne veulent pas nous donner donc la
juste valeur marchande si nous obtenons
une augmentation des redevances et nous
sommes devant le CRTC très bientôt nous
souhaitons parce que là aussi on bloque
toujours même la capacité de se
présenter devant le CRTC pour avoir un
arbitrage de différents afin que cette
redevance là soit décrétée à ce
moment-là on va certainement avoir une
augmentation
suis revenu en provenance des
abonnements vous fermez pas tva sport
pour l'instant non
la décision de l'arbitrage et elle va
être déterminante dans pour l'avenir de
TVA sport est-ce que des vous parler de
belles puis vous parlez souvent de
Radio-Canada également concurrence
déloyale puis vous parlez des géants du
web est-ce que vous vous avez une
responsabilité est-ce que vous vous
reconnaissez une responsabilité dans
certaines décisions certains choix qui
ont pu être fait et qui après coup ne
sont pas les bons c'est-à-dire mais je
sais pas par exemple l'investissement
dans TVA sport ou l'investissement du
côté de Québec également avec le Colisée
puis avec la volonté d'avoir une équipe
mais je pense surtout à TVA sport est-ce
qu'on a pas mis la charrue avant les bus
non je pense que c'était clairement donc
la volonté donc de s'engager dans un
créneau qui allait nous procurer une
croissance
il y avait pas de concurrence RDS était
seul oui effectivement aussi il y avait
le centre Vidéotron il y avait le
Colisée donc c'est un amalgame
d'éléments qui faisait en sorte que la
proposition était intéressante mais
mince seulement si on est rémunéré
adéquatement et c'est belles qui
bloquent cette capacité alors c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous sommes devant
le CRTC et nous faisons des
représentations pour être adéquatement
rémunéré
beaucoup de haute dirigeants de
Vidéotron et de TVA ont quitté au cours
des derniers mois puis des dernières
années si bien qu'en plus d'être PDG de
Québécois vous êtes PDG de Vidéotron en
ce moment et PDG du Groupe TVA
et là en plus vous avez mené la charge
pour acheter freedom montberg est-ce que
ça en fait pas beaucoup pour un seul
homme c'est une très bonne équipe une
très bonne équipe ces vidéos trompe
bonne partie de l'équipe est partie là
dans les dernières vous savez on a
comment on pourrait dire un bain qui est
très fort et puis les personnes qui
étaient là précédemment le sont encore
je pense à l'ingénierie je pense à la
commercialisation je pense au finances
les résultats sont pour le prouver il
suffit d'ailleurs les regarder donc nous
avons la meilleure marge de l'Indus et
cette marge continue à s'améliorer
est-ce que vous allez nommer un PDG à
Vidéotron ou un PDG au Groupe TVA
pas pour l'instant donc vous gardez les
les manettes sur toutes les parties de
l'entreprise la responsabilité qui est
celle qui est soit un président chef de
la direction il va y avoir des
consultations sur la loi sur la qui
vient d'être adopté à Ottawa sur la
diffusion continue en ligne pour fixer
les règles qui vont obliger Netflix
Disney plus et d'autres à valoriser les
créations canadiennes vous voulez
davantage qu'on mette de l'argent dans
un fond que ces entreprises comme
Netflix mettent de l'argent dans un fond
plutôt que plus de création de de
participer à la création canadienne oui
parce que nous les radio diffuseurs
conventionnelles en plus d'être
assujetti évidemment une réglementation
tatiane nous devons également aussi
participer au financement du paysage
audiovisuel canadien donc le fond des
médias existe et justement on veut faire
en sorte que ces entreprises étrangères
qui bénéficient de l'au canadien puisse
également elle aussi contribuée
autrement que en récupérant uniquement
l'auditoire et qu'elle le fasse avec bon
évidemment l'argent du financement qui
est celui qui va faire en sorte qu'on
puisse continuer à avoir un système
aussi riche que celui auquel nous avons
été
assujettiseur effectivement comme nous
le faisons dès aujourd'hui avec le fond
canadien des médias pour lequel
également aussi nous contribuons de
façon significative
monsieur Péladeau il y a toujours plein
de sujets abordés avec vous on va
s'arrêter ici pour aujourd'hui il y a
d'autres sujets certainement mais merci
beaucoup d'avoir acceptévitation
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI